I was about to say it actually Queen H5
is the only move that creates a threat
and Knight G did you see that he play in
no with one second R oh my goodness I
think y leaning back there thinking how
did you not lose on time there Knight G1
defends F3 very importantly and it sets
up for Rook takes H3 this is like
perfectly timed keeping things under
control but yeah moving making that move
on 1 second was it was so close and
we've seen we've seen Sam savian on the
receiving end of that one second he what
can you say he was down to a second and
here you go Knight takes F4 let's let
let let's throw in some and thenen takes
and Rook takes E8 check has done and
queen simply takes the night and we have
got handshakes Ray Robson does it he
takes the win against Yami